ses deux passes elle nous transporte
tout droit dans l'orient du xviiie
siècle
en 1751 le portraitiste à succès jean
baptiste perraudeau rance visite à son
ami aignan thomas défricher un profil
pour réaliser le portrait de toutes les
familles
aignan thomas des friches est alors un
négociant bien installée à orléans mais
c'est comme un amateur éclairé qu'il
souhaite se faire représenter carton de
dessin à la main et en robe de chambre
quant à sa femme elle opte pour la
dernière mode et n'hésitera pas vingt
ans plus tard a demandé à perono de
transformer le bonnet de coton en une
coiffure plus dans le goût des années
ans
non